this is where many headaches start
anyone who's ever worked in a large
office knows what it's like to spend the
entire day under artificial light from a
variety of sources researchers say that
improper lighting can lead to fatigue
difficulty concentrating and for
performance
leeteuk me out of a [ __ ] tribunal light
has three effects on humans more or less
one is the biological effect meaning how
it regulates our biological clock then
light also serves vision of course and
when you process what you've seen it has
a third effect the emotional effect this
emotional effect is important to our
sense of well-being daylight is best
that's why researchers at the fraunhofer
institute for industrial engineering are
working to bring daylight indoors a
luminous ceiling recreates the effect of
passing clouds giving the impression of
being outdoors the lighting here is made
out of 35,000 LEDs that can generate any
desired color the entire effect is
called dynamic light mr. Garrick in
liz's since we've made a few important
findings first people like dynamic light
which we didn't want to take just for
granted and we found the dynamic light
reduces fatigue and improves well-being
we've found that dynamic light is
especially popular with people working
on creative tasks Lloyd and Zach would
be fed
in the early morning natural light is
more blue experiments have shown this
gives concentration a boost
in the late afternoon natural light is
warmer that is more red and that helps
you relax the intelligent desk operates
according to the same principle
particularly the main advantage here is
that individual users can adjust the
illumination and color temperature
according to their needs studies have
shown that in the morning users tend to
favor blue light which helps wake them
up in the late afternoon they're more
likely to select a calming red tinted
light in the summer they select a cooler
hue in the winter a warmer one light
researchers are also building on the
insights of krona biology light helps
regulate our sleep and wake cycles our
moods and many other bodily processes
deepa deutschland excellent fit you
might in the future lighting will keep
getting more intelligent for example it
will know our light story meaning when
we got up when we go to work how much
daylight we've already been exposed to
the lighting of the future will know all
that and automatically adapt to it oh oh
Jesus you do at two and I today until
then we'll have to keep experimenting
ourselves to figure out the best
lighting for various tasks and times a
day